YOU COME BUT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING.
IT MAY BE TO ESTIMATE QUESTION.
SO YOU ARE ALWAYS WELCOME.
THE MICHAEL FLYNN SAGA MANY
ASSUME SPIED ON AND THEN
UNMASKED BY HALF OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BY THE RUSSIAN
INVESTOR.
BUT A RECENT REALLY INTERESTING
PIECE BY FREQUENT SHOW GUEST
MAKES AN INTERESTING, REALLY
COMPELLING POINT.
HE SAYS THAT LYNN’S PHONE CALL
WAS NEVER UNMASKED AT ALL BUT
INSTEAD, HE ARGUES THE FACTS
POINT TO ANOTHER WEIRDER
POSSIBILITY THAT THE CEA WAS
SPYING ON FLYNN AND NEVER
FOLLOWED FAISAL RESTRICTIONS ON
THE FIRST PLACE.
MATT WHITAKER ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND "A BRAND-NEW BOOK "ABOVE THE
LAW" ENTRANCES TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS THEORY
THAT THE CIA, FISA SPIED ON
FLYNN?
>> AS YOU POINTED OUT BECAUSE HE
WAS NOT UNMASKED THERE WAS NO
REQUEST THE TIME OF THE PHONE
CALL ON DECEMBER 29TH UNTIL
REALLY THE WHITE HOUSE MEETING
ON JANUARY 5TH AND ULTIMATELY
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
REQUESTED A MASKING OF GENERAL
FLYNN, PERHAPS ANOTHER
EXPLANATION BECAUSE
JANUARY 3RD OF 2017, ANDY
McCABE WENT TO THE NATIONAL
SECURITY DIVISION HEAD AT DOJ
AND SAID ESSENTIALLY THE
CONTENTS OF THE CALL.
SO THERE IS A PERIOD OF TIME
FROM THE 29TH OF DECEMBER, 2016
AND THE MEETING BETWEEN McCABE
WHERE SOMEONE TOLD McCABE AND
THEN McCABE TRANSMITTED THAT
INFORMATION.
AND THERE IS NO UNMASKING IN
THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
SO IT IS VERY CURIOUS TO SAY THE
LEAST.
>> Tucker: SO YOU WERE IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
EXPLAIN TO US NONLAWYERS, WOULD
IT BE LEGAL FOR THE CIA TO SPY
ON AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THEN
LEAK WHAT THEY FOUND TWO OTHER
AGENCIES IN THE MEDIA?
>> THE SHORT ANSWER IS NO.
THERE ARE CONSTITUTIONAL TENETS
HERE AT PLAY.
THIS HAPPENED WHILE MR. FLYNN
WAS OUT OF THE COUNTRY AND WE
DON’T SPECIFICALLY KNOW WHERE
THE INVESTOR OF RUSSIA WAS
LOCATED APPEARED IT MAY HAVE
BEEN IN D.C. OR RUSSIA SO MAYBE
HAVE BEEN UNDER A DIFFERENT
PROGRAM WERE: FRIENDLY THIRD
COUNTRY.
BUT THE BIGGEST CONCERN IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU POINTED OUT
WHICH IS THIS CONSTITUTIONAL,
VIOLATES THE FOURTH AMENDMENT,
VIOLATES ALL SORTS OF POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES, BUT NONETHELESS
JANUARY 30, McCABE HAD THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THIS VERBATIM
CALL.
>> Tucker: NO ELECTED LEADER
CAN RUN A COUNTRY IN WHICH THE
BIGGEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
AGENCIES OPERATE INDEPENDENTLY
IN VIOLATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION, DEMOCRACY DIES
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO WE HAVE TO FIX THIS.
IT DOESN’T SEEM LIKE ANYBODY IS
REALLY WORKING TO FIX IT.
PLEASE REASSURE ME THAT SOMEONE
IS, BECAUSE I JUST DON’T SEE IT.
>> WELL THE CONSTITUTION IS EVER
RENEWING.
WE CONTINUE TO LIVE UNDER OF
THOSE, AND WE DO NEED OUR
ELECTED AND APPOINTED EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OFFICIALS, INCLUDING THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO FOLLOW
BASIC TENETS OF CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS COUNTRY WILL SUFFER AND
SUFFER GREATLY IF WE DON’T GET
BACK TO THAT BEING THE
FUNDAMENTAL BASIS OF ALL OF THE
SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE LAW AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL IS FOLLOWED EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE OF UNLIKE
MITCH McCONNELL DEMOCRATS
DON’T MESS AROUND AT ALL AND IF
ELECTED PRESIDENT, THE NEXT TIME
ONE IS COME I WILL JUST FIRE
EVERYBODY AND PUT THEIR COUSINS
IN CHARGE OF THESE AGENCIES?
>> WELL, HOPEFULLY FROM THIS
PAINFUL CHAPTER THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS REALLY SINCE THE
TRANSITION OF POWER IN 2016 TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY HAVE LACKED
SOME ADULT SUPERVISION.
I THINK WE ARE SEEING FOLKS PUT
IN BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
BUT THERE IS NO PROMISE THAT
WHEN BIDEN, YOU KNOW, IF TO GET
ELECTED WOULD PUT ADULTS IN
CHARGE OF THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY.
>> HE WOULD PUT WHEELS IN CHARGE